cette année sera donc l'occasion
d'étudier les grands auteurs de la
langue française et surtout vous inciter
à vous exprimer à raconter des histoires
aussi mauvais que ça cette année je me
casse la plus nulle de ma vie écoute
sage samedi j manger une pizza et
regarder la télé dimanche je n'ai rien
fait je n'aurais pas demandé de me faire
un poème en alexandrins là je leur ai
demandé de me raconter leur week-end
samedi je suis allé étudier chi raphaël
hartl je découvrais la maison une odeur
retient mon attention
l'odeur si singulière des femmes de la
classe moyenne
tu trouves pas sachant qu'aucun élève de
16 ans écrivain tout pareil moi ça me
choque pas
un dos tu mets 17 ans qui se moque de
son copain et de sa mère
de retour dans la maison de la famille
normale geda nouveau rafa
s'était lancé dans une parodie skhira
c'est de s'approcher au plus près des
personnages
pourquoi déplacer au présent c'est une
manière de rester dans la maison
je ne sais pas ce que tu cherches c'est
juste de lui apprendre la littérature il
ya une seule question que tu dois le
poser que va-t-il se passer
il a un regard des femmes ou des
personnages de fiction jamais tout ça
devient de plus en plus crédible est de
plus en plus dangereux tu es allé trop
loin c'est vous qui m'avez poussé là
dedans les rafales je veux continuer à
soulever
ça va mal finir je le sens à dallas
vous avez humilié monfils en public tu a
merdé j'ai corrigé son devoir
pas être manipule tu veux lui apprendre
la littérature mais c'est lui qui te
donne une leçon
je pars à la recherche d'une feinte une
fin pour monsieur germain
une fin pour nos professeurs